mon histoire enfin d'amour il ya ça
mes premiers jeux j'ai vécu en tant qu'
en tant que
bah sparring partner j'étais cadet le
fait qu'on m'ait fait confiance enfin
lors de ces jeux a marre a mené avec
l'équipe avec comment les athlètes les
dirigeants ça m'a touché et voilà quoi
moi ça m'a permis à près de gardez ce
cette relation avec mme avec tous les
dirigeants avec enfin les entraîneurs
près en 98 et basse était à la réunion
lé de la réunion et en 2003 c'était à
maurice allais maurice en 2007 à
madagascar
et 2011 aux seychelles je savais faire
ma sixième participation
depuis seychelles
le moment le plus intense et les équipes
à madagascar où j'avais on était deux
par catégorie et là on avait des anciens
et les nouveaux qui était qui étaient
réunis non madagascar s'était médias ni
mais j'ai repoussé après mais là par
équipes c'est un moment
symboliquement deux de fusion avec avec
les autres ou va on ne lâche rien mon
souhait assez voilà que
mc le juno apporte la pareille aux
jeunes aux jeunes
de la réunion que lucien une cohésion
ils vont donner envie à d'autres
personnes de faire la même chose de se
réunir autour d'un projet c'est les jeux
des îles et après de fédérer pour pour
eux après amusé moi je suis au au pôle
espoirs aura des jeunes du pôle espoir
ils vont partir bientôt et ça ça va
motiver ça va être une émulation pour
eux de continuer dans quelques années de
faire la même chose